[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le grand
studio du figaro rire on balance un
petit peu on recadre les caméras c'est
un peu un petit contretemps mais un
contretemps également pour guillaume
roquette
mais ne vous inquiétez pas il va revenir
très vite
on est d'ailleurs avec un ses plis pour
lui plus brillants bras droit je vous
laisse deviner qui on est en tout cas
avec vous on est en direct etc figaro
live et on attend vos points de vue sur
leur confinement qui s'annonce peut-on
vraiment se le permettre c'est la
question je vous propose sur laquelle je
vous propose de débattre sachant que on
a 8 % de récession 20% de dépression et
on va donc en débattre avec vous et
également avec gilles smadja directeur
de cabinet du maire de nanterre ancien
directeur de cabinet de la ministre
communiste des sports marie george
buffet bonsoir gilles merci de renom sur
le plateau avec la lire avec plaisir
partagé et face à vous dont
jean-christophe puis sans vouloir être
vinet directeur adjoint de la rédaction
du figaro magazine possible quand je
disais qu'il y avait un mec brillant qui
étaient en plateau je pense quand même
que les internautes ont tout de suite
deviné ils sont intelligents en ruines
du fig mag d'ailleurs une question un
débat peut-on encore vaincre l'islamisme
est sûre ça et bien j'attends vos points
de vue on va y revenir donc en deuxième
partie mais d'abord ce supplice chinois
sans jeu de mots emmanuel macron va-t-il
parler que va-t-il se passer
oui manuel macron devrait parler par la
question c'est de savoir quand et que
va-t-il se passer que va-t-il annoncer
un confinement le week-end une partie
des commerces fermés les vacances
prolongées alors officiellement emmanuel
macron attend le résultat d'une étude
flash sur le variant anglais et une
autre sur les faits réels du couvre-feu
ça c'est ce qui est annoncé mais en
coulisses selon notre confrère arthur
berda du service politique du figaro
donc vous allez retrouver l'article dans
le chatt l'équivalent demandé à vincent
le noble le président tient tête à la
ligne pro confinement incarné par le
tandem jean castex olivier ferrand
respectivement premier ministre et
ministre des sports l'enjeu de ce
de se démonter de la santé pardon
effectivement janvier la commission
après olivier v alors j'avais merci
beaucoup donc merci à jean christophe
vissant de cette précision
olivier ferrand et jusqu'à présent
ministre de la santé
l'enjeu donc de ceux de ce bras de fer
au sommet de l'état c'est d'éviter une
crise sociale et un autre mal décrit par
emmanuel hirsch
ce qui me semble important et je pense
que le président république l'a compris
c'est d'intégrer effectivement c'était
fondremand de psychologique d'une partie
de la société
mais la réponse est pas uniquement en
soutien psychologique c'est également en
force démocratique payer quand on a dit
que les étudiants pourraient bénéficier
de la possibilité d'aller voir un psy
c'est aussi très péjoratif de réduire la
crise qu'on vit un aspect médico
psychologique alors dans le figaro mais
je précise le medad mersch
hirsch est bel et bien le frère de
martin hirsch ok lui-même patron de
l'assistance publique de la pêche à la
pêche
l'agencé régionale de santé c'est
aurélien rousseau qui est un énarque et
qui n'a aucune compétence dans la
matière de sacs et les avait twitté
effectivement pour l'instant j'attends
de savoir quelles étaient les les faits
les faits d'armes des valdoisiens
rousseau pour être à ce poste là et
j'attends toujours la réponse
dans le figaro boris cyrulnik indique
que les français en régie par l'humour
et sur les réseaux sociaux en organisant
des rituels ou grâce à un engouement
pour la cuisine
aujourd'hui ce n'est plus le cas nous
sommes entrés dans une période
d'engourdissement psychique provoquée
par la répétition
on a également la société des pédiatres
qui publie une lettre dans laquelle il
est écrit la santé mentale et sociale
des enfants ne doit pas être sacrifiée
j'ajoute gilles ce match à deux chiffres
donc on lisait 23% des français
déclarent un état dépressif 61 % des
18-25 ans estime que les crises
sanitaires aura des conséquences
négatives sur leur santé mentale
je sais qu'elle est l'attachement vous
la santé des français mais est ce que
dans ces conditions il est vraiment
raisonnable de recombiner quand vous
interrogez les médecins généralistes ce
que j'ai fait récemment dans ma ville
quand vous interrogez les médecins
généralistes ils vous disent
qu'aujourd'hui ils ont beaucoup plus de
patients non mais en nombre très
impressionnant qui viennent là pour des
problèmes d'angoise d'anxiété de stress
de dépression que pour le coc vide mais
en nombre vraiment totalement
incomparables et quel que soit l'âge
quelle que soit la situation sociale
quel que soit le quartier moi je crois
que je crois que la souffrance actuelle
d'abord il faut bien mesurer qu'on n'est
plus du tout dans le même état d'esprit
qu'il y à un presqu'un an au moment du
démarrage de la crise
rappelez vous le 16 mars 2020 au
lendemain du premier tour des élections
municipales quand le président de la
république annonce le confinement
il y à une écrasante majorité des
français qui approuvent cette mesure et
qui adhèrent à cette mesure et qui se
dit on va le faire tous ensemble parce
qu'on va sauver des vies parce qu'on va
permettre aux soignants ne pas être
ensevelies sous le flot des mâles le
flux des malades qui arrivent en
réanimation et donc on le fait tous on y
on y va et on le fait tous avec avec pas
enthousiaste mais on le fait tous en
étant conscient que c'est ça qu'il faut
faire aujourd'hui
dix mois après vous avez une majorité de
français qui ne fait plus confiance au
gouvernement pour nous sortir de la
situation donc la réponse à la question
c'est pour vous parce que vous l'avez
dit sur le plateau
sur ce plateau que l'impératif
sanitaires étaient était le plus
important est ce que aujourd'hui
vous pensez que leur confinement et
raisonnable dans le contexte que vous
décrivez à condition de donner des
perspectives de savoir où l'on va on
n'attend pas seulement du président de
la république qu'ils nous disent voilà
la situation on la connaît on n'attend
pas seulement qu'ils nous disent voilà à
quoi vont servir les mesures que je vous
propose que nous avons décidé de prendre
on sait très bien que les mesures qui
vont être prises elles ont pour objectif
de faire baisser le nombre de
contaminations et de faire baisser la
tension dans les services de réanimation
ça on le sait mais par contre en
revanche au col non nous ce que les les
gouvernants ceux qui nous gouvernent ne
nous disent pas c'est où l'on va quelles
sont les perspectives d'en sortir
quelles sont les hypothèses de sortie de
crise à combien de millions de vaccinés
par exemple peut-on envisager d'inverser
la tendance et de reprendre
progressivement une vie normale à
quelles conditions sanitaires peut-on
imaginer de réouvrir les cinémas les
théâtres les salles de musique voilà les
restaurants c'est ça que l'on attend
c'est à dire de se projeter au-delà de
l'immédiat et surtout de dire toute la
vérité toute la vérité c'est à dire même
s'il ya des choses qui ne sont pas
forcément agréable à entendre mais mais
en tout cas de ne de ne pas inventer des
histoires
voyez de ne pas recommencer l'histoire
de les vaccins ou des masses parce que
les vaccins
franchement le ministre de la santé qui
au début de l'année invente invente la
stratégie de la lenteur assumer pour
simplement justifier qu'on n'a pas de
vaccin on an'a pas en assez grand nombre
ça il faut arrêter après notre manière
de gouverner lire et la crise
mais justement
jean-christophe j'entends ce que dit
gilles mais ce que on peut aujourd'hui
voyez en justement la multiplication des
variants voyant là la situation qui même
dans les autres pays est très fluctuante
on peut offrir des perspectives on peut
offrir un horizon c'est impossible de
répondre à ce genre de questions ça fait
des mois qu'on discute un jour j'entends
je repose la question différemment mais
est ce que est ce que on peut se dire
légitimement que deux gouvernements pour
offrir une perspective d'un noël un
horizon sachant que même raison que
c'est bouché alors c'est pas est ce qui
peut ce qu'ils doivent le faire je
souscris totalement ce que gilles
d'ailleurs sir onyx matin l'ancien d'un
enfant interview dit si les gens ne
supportent plus n'accepte plus le
confinement la perspective du
confinement c'est parce qu'il ya cet
effet effectué en deux répétitions et
d'absence de perspective d'avenir ce
moment donné on a besoin d'avoir un but
si on nous dit il y en a pour six mois
et n'a pour 12 mois une chose mais là on
a toujours une sorte de fluctuation et
puis cette acceptabilité s'est effondré
par le fait que les français ont le
sentiment et dieu sait si on leur a dit
de cette très bien comportés globalement
à 99% respecter les gestes barrière se
laver tout le monde porte un masque
aujourd'hui tout le monde tout le monde
fait globalement très attention et le
sentiment que les gens sont à la hauteur
de l'événement mais que les gouvernants
ne le sont pas avec ses comédies de
masques de vaccins d'autojustification
d'absence de reconnaissance
effectivement de culpabilité de demande
de pardon dire qu'on s'est trompé
maintenant on va essayer de le faire
comme il faut et l'idée que les gens ne
reconnaissent pas qu'il que le
gouvernement ne reconnaît pas qui s'est
trompé dans ses stratégies et qui le
femise en permanence et quand on est
aujourd'hui à inventer des mots en
permanence le confinement adapter le
confinement hybride le confinement
je ne sais pas quoi pour ne pas serrer
pour ne pas dire que l'épidémie
on parle de plateau montant plateau
montant on en est là comme oxymore c'est
formidable un plateau montant plateau
c'est plat donc ça peut pas monter 20 on
en est là c'est un jour là et les gens
sont pas idiots la bernerie dit mais il
va bien quelque chose ne va pas dans le
lexique dents
dans la phraséologie du gouvernement ça
cache quelque chose
ça cache quelque chose donc on a plus
confiance dans convient bon ya pas de
perspective en fait ils nous cachent la
vérité qui est atroce et donc
et donc un désespoir qui se manifeste
avec ses passions qui se multiplient
dans les cabinets de l'est si pour une
fois on faisait appel à l'intelligence
collective et si pour une fois on
considérer que les français sont
suffisamment adulte mature intelligent
pour comprendre la situation et si pour
une fois on mettait tout sur la table et
si pour une fois on disait ben voilà les
vaccins on a un problème avec les
vaccins pour telle et telle raison et si
on disait voilà quel prix on les a les
médias des problèmes oui mais avec le
problème c'est qu'on lâche on l'a on ne
dit pas les choses et et c'est ce
sentiment d'être pris pour des enfants
d'être totalement infantilisée qui qui
crée un désarroi total dans l'opinion
publique lui cette histoire de défendre
comité de défense sanitaire qui fait
kiffer qui fait peur qui donne
l'impression d'un comité privé et quand
vers en fait une conférence de presse
j'ai pas leur dire ce qui s'est dit à
l'intérieur ce qui s'est passé ah bon il
ya des militaires qui ce qu'ils disent
non plus n'ont pas le droit de parler
on a l'impression que c'est les
scientifiques qui ont pris la main qui
ont pris le pouvoir à tort ou à raison
et tout ça devrait effectivement
abandonnés être en transparence le
parlement a raison du relais en disant
mais associé nous les musées les
municipalités les régions les
départements ont tout pris l'initiative
de la mission d'information sur le
comider mais voilà mes saisissions des
bars
c'est ahurissant on voudrait lever
l'information et à force de bloquer
l'information les gens se disent mais si
de la bloque
c'est qu'ils nous cachent de ce fait que
le président de la république l'a appuyé
la décision qu'il va prendre et qu'il va
annoncer dimanche ou lundi sûr non plus
le conseil de défense
ce fameux conseil de défense qui a
pourtant de tout décider jusqu'à présent
mais sur une consultation du parlement
selon les syndicats des élus etc
ça montre savent absolument c'est un
échec total c'est de la méthode qui a
prévalu une interview dans le
une autre un autre fait puisqu'on
parlait des vaccins c'est que les primo
injection de vaccin de vaccin donc les
trucs de recevoir les premières
injections de vaccin sont suspendus dans
trois des plus grandes une région
touchée par le virus le haut de france
bourgogne franche comté et 2009 france
faute de doses suffisantes
est ce que dans ces conditions pardon
nous reposer la question on peut éviter
un confinement
non on peut pas l'éviter non sa part
inévitable mais à condition que l'on
dise exact que l'on donne tous les
éléments de ce2 de ce qui va être décidé
si par exemple on nous annonce que on
considère que les écoles sont des foyers
de contamination
voilà d'abord il faut le faut le prouver
faut donner des faits s'il s'avère que
les écoles sont des foyers de
contamination à ce moment là on nous
annonce à ce moment là la mesure c'est
de dire au delà des vacances scolaires
de février
il y aura peut-être une ou deux semaines
durant lesquelles on va installer à une
école dématérialisée à distance pour une
courte durée et surtout en veillant à
lutter contre le décrochage scolaire
alors que on n'avait pas du tout mais
oui bien sûr accor a réalisé un nul à
condition de ne pas dire c'est une
prolongation des vacances n'a pas tout à
fait d'ailleurs on est à l'école à
domicile parce qu'on est aujourd'hui qui
va faire ce qui est un confinement
général parce que quand il ya l'école à
domicile c'est à dire que les parents
doivent rester quand même à la maison et
donc ça ça dès qu'on a des conséquences
à des contraintes sur les jeunes je ne
suis pas décideur je ne sais pas si
c'est ça qui va être décidé
je n'en sais rien je n'ai je n'ai pas
les éléments pour pouvoir décider une
chose pareil parce que je ne sais pas
quel est le niveau présumé de
contamination dans nos écoles
mais en tout cas si c'est ça qui est
annoncé il faut expliquer pourquoi je
sais ça qui est annoncée juste être une
question peut-être une indication dans
une crise comme celle là on imagine
plein de
jean plein de choses puisque comme le
disait jean christophe tout à l'heure
quand ça se passe justement dans un
ministère dans un tel est la difficulté
bien sûr on imagine que c'est de choisir
cette décidé mais quelles sont les
difficultés concrètes auxquelles le
décideur est confronté ces deux d'avoir
à choisir en permanence entre la vérité
factuelle celle qui est étayée par un
certain nombre de faits de chiffres
voilà deux réalités qu'on vous qu'on
vous donne que vous avez en face des
yeux
et puis la politique la communication
politique c'est à dire est ce que ça va
passer dans l'opinion
est-ce que ça va être acceptée est ce
que ça va être compris est-ce que ce
voilà est donc en permanence
vous avez d'un côté la réalité qui vous
rattrape qui est qui est implacable et
de l'autre vous avez la stratégie
politique voilà et donc c'est il faut il
faut essayer à chaque fois de prendre la
non seulement de prendre la décision
mais mais surtout de la de l'apprendre
et de façon à ce qu'elle soit comprise
acceptée et qui est un niveau d'adhésion
à la décision qu'ils soient suffisants
et l'illustration de ça c'est quand
emmanuel macron parle de guerre très
bien on entre en guerre et on a là on a
l'impression que les généraux qui sont
partis en guerre sont pas sont pas à la
hauteur sont incapables de mener des
batailles ont des régimes ans après la
bataille ans donc communication
politique mais le mot guerre qui est
très fort qui était sûrement justifié
pour mobiliser les gens et après on fait
la guerre mais on a fait mal et est donc
un canton c'est malaga en change de
généraux généralement on change on
change de chef militaire s'ils ne sont
pas à la hauteur de l'événement la
parole la parole chers internautes à
particulier sophie qui nous suit sur
youtube les personnes âgées qui ne
reçoivent plus de visites se laisse
mourir c'est effectivement des
témoignages qu'on a depuis le 1er
confinement laeticia qui raconte que sa
soeur qui en dernière année à la fac en
souffrent
bien qu'elle vit chez ses parents elle a
la sensation que son diplôme n'aura pas
de valeur et enzo qui nous dit les
français souffrent déjà de plus emmanuel
macron a ajouté selon lui de
l'incertitude à l'incertitude en
procrastine ans le confinement en
lui-même est insupportable c'est le
manque de visibilité qui engendre excité
ce que nous disait gilles à l'instant
kriss kross dudit la consommation
d'alcool explose c'est un signe par daba
d'argent galère en permanence pas de
sport pas d'activité pas de resto je
sens la détresse arrivée nous dit sam
le pire est que cette question se pose
vraiment nous dit benjamin va tous les
classes et s'il est ce que c'est nous
qui l'avons posée cela va engendrer de
très graves conséquences économiques
sociales et morales et l'entarteur qui
nous lisent sur virus rend dingue les
gens et dernier témoignage celui de hunt
que ce soit les étudiants qui se glisse
de plus en plus vers la révolte et la
précarité des salariés qui voient leur
entreprise sombrer ou encore les parents
qui vont empirer l'orgueilleuse ciblant
kernel et maintient pas à l'école tout
le monde va devenir dingue si leur
confie c'est quand même vous à cela le
front puis en attendant les dans les
remontées qu'on a rajouté janvier passé
avec les p'tits cracks ce à ce tableau
que oui je vais rajouter une chose c'est
que vous savez ce qui ajoute aussi de
l'incertitude comme ça de de la
dépression presse de l' angoisse c'est
aussi le cas aux scientifiques
c'est-à-dire le fait qu' un certain
nombre de gens qui sont censés savoir
des épidémiologistes des virologues des
grands professeurs de la guerre aux
valeurs oui oui c'est à dire le sasac ça
déstabilise aussi l'opinion ça parce que
quand vous avez alors franchement ce
sont des gens pour qui plus tôt j'avais
plutôt de la sympathie du respect par
exemple vous prenez here i come
franchement moi je tout ce que j'avais
lu de lui cela sur l'épidémie je
trouvais ça assez sens est assez
rationnel assez argumenté to marry comme
il nous annonce la première chose qui
nous dit à propos du vaccin surtout il
faut s'en méfier quoi première chose qui
nous disent il faut surtout s'en méfier
alors et rectifie 48 heures après il dit
non non j'ai pas voulu dire ça mais
franchement quand vous voulez vous lui
en voulez je l'argent veut aller semer
filet avec sa jambe de 7 de celle des 10
48 heures en veille scientifique de
de ne pas de ne pas assez intégré le
fait que être chercheur c'est une chose
être passé dans les médias c'est autre
chose
voilà et que et que ne pas savoir
maîtriser la parole publique quand on
s'adresse à des millions de personnes et
qu'on est en plus sensés représenter la
vérité dans ce domaine là il faut faire
il faut faire attention quand par
exemple le professeur karine lacombe
nous dit vous inquiétez pas l'été
prochain c'est fini le dis on lui a pas
mis un pistolet sur la tempe pour
qu'elle le dise
elle le dit et puis 48 heures après le
zino non j'ai pas voulu dire ça non non
c'est beaucoup trop tôt pour donner une
perspective et tout ça il faut qu'il
mesure quand même les dégâts que ça fait
dans la tête des gens parce que euh on
est censé se fier ce qui nous raconte
nous on est on est pas on n'est pas
virologues on n'est pas spécialiste des
épidémies de maladies respiratoires donc
évidemment on est obligé de se faire
dans gilles
la question c'est est ce que le problème
n'est pas le statut qu'on donne à cette
parole là et le statut que le politique
a donné à cette part lui certains dira
et les médias certains diront d'avoir
abdiqué cette parole
cb les médias mais dans ce cas là on ne
peut pas laisser le propre de ces
paroles et même des sciences c'est que
chacun puisse s'exprimer
mais est ce que le problème n'est pas
aussi le fait que le politique s'est
caché derrière ces décisions là pour
pouvoir justement les faire accepter par
l'opinion en tout cas sans doute en tout
cas là il ya une chose qu'aujourd'hui on
sait c'est que quand il s'agit de
décisions qui concernent la vie des gens
il faut que ce soit les politiques qui
les prennent ce n'est pas drôle pour les
jeunes je les plains mais je pense qu
aussi aux personnes âgées de laisser
complètement à l'abandon
ainsi que les personnes qui vivent seuls
qui se retrouve encore plus isolés nous
dit sylvie c'est la question également
qu'on vous reposer sur twitter leur
confinement va-t-il engendré trop de
souffrance et vous répondez oui à 66%
vous pose une autre question sont un
sujet tout aussi grave qui est celui du
séparatisme islamistes le projet de loi
vous savez en débat en ce moment à
l'assemblée et l'opposition tire à
boulet rouge vous propose d'abord
d'écouter le député des alpes-maritimes
eric ciotti
est-ce qu'ils étaient censés lutter
contre l'islamisme qui n'osent même pas
citer le mot islamisme je déposerai un
amendement pour d interdire
définitivement le port du burkini dans
les piscines ou sur les plages
françaises nettement la basant sur le
port du voile de l'e solex je les fais
sur le port du voile également pour les
accompagnants scolaires mais aussi pour
les usagers de certains services publics
critique aussi les contre-propositions
aussi de la part de la présidente du
rassemblement national c'était hier sur
micro de france info marine le pen je
considère que ce projet de loi est
totalement inefficace et je vais même
aller plus loin que cela
je pense que comme d'habitude avec en
marche en fait ils font une oie qui tape
sur absolument tout le monde parce que
et donc attentes à la liberté
individuelle de tout le monde parce
qu'ils sont incapables d'avoir le
courage de s'attaquer précisément à ceux
qui luttent contre la république
alors du côté nord marc justement voici
la réponse ce matin d'horreur berger
toujours sur le plateau de france à
l'eure choses de manière très claire
évidemment on s'attaque à l'islamisme ou
séparatisme islamiste a été dit par le
président de la république dès son
discours des mureaux et c'est justement
l'un des objets majeurs de ce projet de
loi le manière enfin séparé
l'organisation entre le culte et le
culturel pour éviter vous savez d'avoir
ces fausses associations culturelles qui
malheureusement servent de terreau
souvent au séparatisme islamiste est il
déjà trop tard pour lutter contre le
séparatisme islamistes la question qu'on
pose sur twitter c'est également le
titre d'un des articles du dossier du
figaro magazine consacré à ce sujet dans
ce dossier jean christophe géral darmana
présente cinq champs de bataille ce sont
ces beaux esprits ben il est présente
mais il est on l'a mis en discussion
avec bernard rougier qui ce sociologue
écrit un livre la dernière sur les
territoires conquis de l'islamisme et
qui justement le prend au mot sur
certaines îles ont ils un certain nombre
de points communs d'accord commun mais
je trouve que ce que dit
ce que ce que raptor que souvent bien
arrosées à gérard d'émana et darmanin
pardon est frappé au coin du bon sens
notamment sur quelque chose de très
important sur ce projet de loi qui est
de dire très bien en lutte contre
l'islamisme contre le séparatisme
islamistes alors oublions le fait que le
camp encore berger dit on se bat très
clairement quand tu lis a mis ces noms
c'est pas très clairement parce que si
c'est clair il y aurait le mot et
séparatisme islamistes il n'y est pas
pour des raisons comme disait gilles
tout à l'heure sans doute qui serait
retoqué par le conseil constitutionnel
mais admettons que ce combat soit
accepté et gérald darmanin diamant donné
il faut absolument empêcher que les
musulmans considèrent qu'il s'agit d'une
attaque contre eux contre contre contre
contre leur religion et il faut éviter
que ce qu'on croit que que cette lutte
5e mondial c'est un combat qui qui qui
doit être mené
clairement
et ne pas ne pas faire de concessions à
ce qui concerne par exemple qu'il s'agit
de d'un anti islam afin de lentilles
qu'en dirait anti musulmanisme d'état le
racisme d'état d'islamophobie détail
cloche au leader donc d'arman darmanin
dis donc il faut lutter contre ça or
l'état aujourd'hui finances dans les
universités notamment des associations
qui sont justement cultuel et culturel
pardon une comédie hoarau berger qui
prône cette idée que l'état français est
raciste islamophobe en décision donc il
ya un double discours qu'il n'y a pas de
transparence c'est dire l'état peut pas
dire à la fois il faut lutter contre
cela qui nous accusent de tous les maux
parce que ce qu'on fait c'est pas contre
les musulmans de settat et en même temps
en finance
officiellement d'aider des associations
qui sont dix associations anti racistes
anti à jenny cet anti colonialiste des
colonialistes ca et qui explique je
matin midi et soir à leurs étudiants que
l'état français est raciste colonialiste
donc il ya une sorte de distorsion est
frappante d'où est venu ce projet de loi
d'un discours aux mureaux
ce projet de loi il fait suite à quoi il
fait suite à un événement très précis
qui est l'assassinât de samuel bâti par
un terroriste c'est son assassinat c'est
ça est ce que cette ce projet de loi est
ce que ce projet de loi qui ne s'appelle
plus d'ailleurs projet de loi sur le
séparatisme etc qui s'appelle projets de
lois confortant le respect des principes
de la république
confortant le respect des principes la
république
est-ce que ce projet de loi est de
nature à lutter contre le terrorisme
absolument pas ça n'a rien à voir la
laïcité n'a jamais lutté contre le
terrorisme
ce n'est pas la laïcité qui permet de
lutter contre les répertorie ce qui
permet de lutter contre le terrorisme
c'est la police c'est le renseignement
c'est le sait la surveillance dans les
milieux pénitentiaire c'est la
coopération entre les différentes
polices dans les différents états ça ça
permet de lutter contre le terrorisme
mais excusez moi mais j'ai lu le projet
de loi les 51 article d'abord ce qui est
frappant c'est que la quasi totalité des
articles de ce texte ce sont des
dispositions qui existent déjà écrites
d'une autre manière dans d'autres textes
de loi par exemple la lutte contre le
mariage forcé mais aujourd'hui c'est
interdit
mariages forcés et je peux vous dire que
dans patiente au nombre de mines est en
train de dire il sait que si on
appliquer les lois existantes c'est
notamment ce que nous dit chris penseuse
ont déjà respecter la loi sur la burqa
ça suffirait mais les lois elles
existent contre la polygamie contre le
mariage forcé et je vais vous dire un
truc il ya un article très intéressant
c'est l'article 18 qui veulent lutter
contre la haine numérique 1 c'est-à-dire
l'incitation le fait que ça c'est quoi
c'est la réponse au fait que samuel
pâtit on a mis son nom on a jeté son nom
en pâture sur les réseaux sociaux est
quelqu'un évidemment s'est monté à la
tête il est allé le voir il a tué voilà
donc on fait un article de loi là dessus
mais ça existe déjà ça dans la loi si
demain quelqu'un mais mon nom sur
facebook où je ne sais où en dix ans
gilles smadja il faut aller lui casser
la gueule parce que c'est un sale type
oui l'habitat tel endroit etc mais il
est arrêté il est interrogé en garde à
vue et il est sanctionné par la justice
c'est interdit de faire ça aujourd'hui
il ya même un système qui aujourd'hui
surveille la toile pour repérer
justement ces agissements ça s'appelle
found ph
aero est et vous savez qu'il ya combien
de cyber policiers et cyber gendarmes
qui s'occupe de phares aux c'est-à-dire
qu'ils s'occupent de contrôler ça vous
vous rendez compte sept jours sur sept
24 heures sur 24 il y à 28 policiers 28
à tel point c'est tellement énorme que
le ministre de l'intérieur il a annoncé
quand même qu'il allait créer 100 postes
pour pharos dans donc vous voyez le
problème c'est que faire croire aux
français que par ce projet de loi on va
le faire reculer le terrorisme on va
lutter contre le terrorisme non c'est ça
c'est ça n'est pas ça les mêmes à lire
vous êtes ça n'est pas dire la vérité
aux gens mais le sujet ce n'est pas le
terrorisme et le séparatisme
or si ce qui ne va pas dans ce projet de
loi moi je considère que le séparatisme
pourquoi il existe un séparatisme sens
parce que l'islam propose une contre
société propose un projet un projet
global politico religieux qui a sa
cohérence car ces traditions kassiry de
casser et qu'est ce que nous on oppose
laïcité république
des mots des notions qui sont quand même
globalement abstraite quel est le projet
collectif que propose la laïcité qu'elle
est rendue des petites réponses ou non
il a vu là où je ne peux pas vous suivre
ainsi fin à des mois javier pas
s'accrocher coûte et moi j'allais
image un projet dit je le vois au
travail ville comme celui j'habite je
vis et je travaille dans une ville où il
y a plusieurs milliers je ne sais pas
quelle proportion dans tout cas un
nombre important de nos concitoyens qui
sont de confession musulmane et
franchement nous allez nous dire
aujourd'hui que ses concitoyens là ces
français musulmans
ils sont une menace pour la république
mais alors c'est totalement à côté de la
plaque mais c'est totalement à côté de
la plaque
ça ne c'est même insupportable de penser
ça parce que là du coup cette on désigne
on désigne une communauté qui dit la loi
désigne une communauté c'est maintenant
elle ne peut pas le faire c'est
d'ailleurs ce qui explique qu'il n'ya
pas le mot islam dedans parce que ça
serait retoqué immédiatement évidemment
ce serait jugée anticonstitutionnelle
mais ce que je veux dire c'est que au
départ
en réalité vous savez il ya une
gouvernance qui a été instaurée sous
nicolas sarkozy
c'est une gouvernance qui consiste à
répondre à l'émotion par des lois même
si elles existent même si elles existent
tant pis on en refait les mêmes mais au
moins on donne le sentiment aux gens
qu'on agisse n'hésitez pas son nom mais
c'est une tentation forte de tous les
gouvernements ce que je vends répond à
l'émotion par la loi à dallas on est
typiquement dans ce cas de figure
voilà il ya dans tana tenta horrible
ignoble et bien au lieu de lutter contre
le terrorisme avec des moyens ce prix
facial mais si ça c'est sage et le sujet
c'est que pendant des décennies la
france le projet global de la communauté
france suffisait pour que des musulmans
s'intègre dans ce projet et l'acceptent
parce que les 20 projets solides y avait
une histoire ya une tradition une fierté
on était fier de devenir français
combien le bachaga boualem était vice
président de l'assemblée nationale était
fier d'être français c'est un art qui
pourquoi abandonner ces gens là ne se
sont ils ne sont sont ils plus senti en
adéquation avec le projet français au
point vous donnez un projet qui n'est
pas financé ni rien dit quand vous dit
arabe
quand vous dites est un projet qui
religieux moi je peux vous dire n 4 il a
besoin quasiment 100 99 % mais ils
posent des musulmans de nanterre que je
connais qui sont mes amis sont mes
bijoux mono non sauf saurez vous dit
la meilleure à saint denis à montreuil
je pourrais vous dire la même chose dans
beaucoup de banlieues je peux vous dire
que ses concitoyens là et bien là dans
le blick ça marche
la république sa large banon 6,6 à
manger de fer denis projet de loi non
plus mais oui ça a tiré dans la
communication politique crée une
ambiance pour créer une ambiance parce
qu'évidemment il y en a certains qui
rêve ciotti marine le pen rêve que la
présidentielle se déroule sur ce sujet
là et c'est ça qui est filée gens très
sage ans a offert chacun à chacun
d'entre nous regarde ce que voulait dire
d'abord il ya quand même un livre qui a
été écrit par georges bensoussan il ya
maintenant une vingtaine d'années qui
s'appelle les territoires perdus de la
république et bernard oger écrit des
territoires conquis de l'islamisme donc
est-ce que question pour vous il n'ya
pas justement aprem de
territorialisation 6 et de séparation en
fait c'est territoriale géographiques
comme dirait guy lui a basé sur une
culture hostile à la république c'est
moi pour moi il existe un séparatisme et
celui là on n'en parle jamais et c'est
ainsi pour moi c'est là que se trouve le
terreau de toutes les dérives
c'est le séparatisme social parce que
quand on concentre les mêmes populations
dans les mêmes quartiers
quand on concentre la pauvreté quand on
concentre les ghettos scolaires dans les
mêmes endroits
quand vous avez des communes qui
refusent la mixité sociale qui refusent
de construire des logements sociaux et
que ça pour conséquence de faire en
sorte que beaucoup de nos concitoyens
qui sont les plus précaires les plus
pauvres les sans emploi eh bien ils sont
toujours dans les mêmes endroits
ce séparatisme là il est il est source
de beaucoup d'exclusion il est source
d'une perte de confiance dans la
capacité de la république aujourd'hui
justement à générer de l'intégration et
bien ce séparatisme là c'est celui là
qu'il faut combattre
c'est contre celui là qu'il faut agir
expliqué le coureur il est là il est
aussi sociale mais je suis pas d'accord
pourquoi aussi dans ce séparatisme
social où il y avait des gens de toutes
nationalités de toutes religions 2
de tout ce que vous voulez abandonner il
ne s'est plus agi que de la même type du
même type de gens qui habitaient
pourquoi les petits blancs ont fini par
quitter ses quartiers là alors qu'ils
étaient du même niveau social serré
faible que les autres trouve
qu'aujourd'hui les populations issues de
l'immigration se confondent avec les
populations les plus pauvres et les plus
précaires
voilà pourquoi ils saluent cette analyse
sociale comme moi qu'il a fait beaucoup
de sociologues marqués des paroles des
populations les plus pauvres les plus
précaires vous appelez ça le petit blanc
mais il ya toute une partie de la
communauté juive également
de dix neuvième arrondissement de paris
ou bien qui était en seine saint denis
qui elle même est partie justement part
du fait de cette pression ça existe mais
vous croyez vous croyez que dans la
communauté juive que je connais bien
vous croyez que voilà vous croyez qu'il
n'y a pas ce phénomène aussi du fait
notamment chez ceux qui sont les plus
précaires les plus pauvres tous sont qui
ressort en perte de repères vous croyez
qu'il n'ya pas aussi un phénomène de
repli identitaire
vous croyez qu'on est épargné par sanaa
communauté j'ai lu ment pas de nature à
menacer la république non non absolument
pas a besoin et la cohésion de là mais
ce que je veux dire c'est que à partir
du moment où vous vous avez vous êtes
dans une société qui s'avèrent
incapables d'intégrer par le biais du
travail de la formation du logement à
partir du moment où la société ne et
apparaît comme comme ayant fait faillite
dans beaucoup de domaines et bien voilà
l'explication asocial vous prendrez pas
que sociale cepas comme gramsci non là
qu elle nie pas les lieux dès maintenant
elle n'est pas que social et culturel et
l aelies au contenu même des religions
et tout ça bien sûr on pourrait débat
mais évacuer je vous proclamez le sais
pas mais moi je trouve qu'à montrer
cherche un de ces livres si c'est tout
un business quand même à la halle il ya
beaucoup d'argent qui est déversée par
un certain nombre de pays étrangers et
de par des personnes qui elles ne sont
pas pauvres et qui gît dans un état de
mentalité séparation oui d'accord mais
moi si je vous ai si j'étais député je
déposerai au moins un amendement sur ce
projet de loi pour être beaucoup plus
dur à l'égard des communes qui
n'appliquent pas la loi sur la mixité
sociale et qui de ce fait renforce le
séparatisme est ce que le problème n'est
pas de lutter contre les causes de
de ce séparatisme qui sont pas
simplement sociale mais qui peut être
l'immigration par exemple plutôt que
d'obliger certaines communes à se
répartir cette cette immigration non
c'est pas des migrations ils sont
français
25 sont français faut arrêter de penser
immigration sont des français sont des
français 82 france 90% des musulmans de
nanterre et de saint denis à montreuil
et bobigny sont des français juste une
alors j'ai fait l'objection agile
l'objection pour vaud jean-christophe
sur justement ce que disait gilles il
risque de stigmatisation d'une partie de
la population musulmane risque et nous
dit il ne faut pas mettre tous les
musulmans dans le même sac chez les
catholiques aussi il ya des extrémistes
peut-être que vous allez répondre à ça
moi une objection par rapport à ça
peut-être ce frisquet c'est dans le
livre d'un de quelqu'un qui n'est pas un
ami politique de jude smadja mais
philippe de villiers sur justement que
les clochards être ont-elles de sonner
et qui dit qu'il faut bien opérer une
distinction entre l'islam et villiers a
des mots très durs et radicaux à l'égard
de l'islam et même de la région religion
musulmane et 10 des musulmans il dit les
musulmans ne les français musulmans
n'ont pas forcément une vie c'est pas
séparatistes ou une vie et tu indiques
bon c'est la thèse de villiers qui dit
que l'islam porte en lui-même plutôt des
germes justement de qui incline vers ce
séparatisme
oui mais encore une fois je pense que
tant que la france n'est pas capable de
proposer un projet globalement
intégrationniste un projet de presque
une transcendance comme c'était le cas
au tout début de la troisième république
etc etc etc est telle qu'elle ne fait
que répondre à des coups de boutoir des
agressions une déliquescence sociale
bien d'accord et tant qu'il ya ça et
qu'à côté on a chez certains musulmans
l'impression que l'islam dépasse les
frontières c'est un projet nous aussi on
est là à dire il faut dépasser les
frontières il faut faire l'europe vers
la mondialisation à l'islam ses manières
dit la même chose il faut dépasser les
frontières il n'y a pas de français et
d'italien de d'égyptiens de libanais d
un dia
il ya l'islam luma etc et c'est un
projet collectif avec une grande vie
intérieure proposé aussi qui est pas
forcément vers dieu soit loué même pas
du tout l'appel au meurtre ou de
terrorisme et a tué les il ya un projet
et ce projet n'est pas forcément
compatible à 100% avec le projet de la
république laïque française est temps
que la laïcité donnant l'impression
d'être une espèce d'armes de défense
justement contre l'islamisme et
peut-être même contre l'islam et en
quelle n'apparaîtra que comme comme cela
je pense qu'il ya un certain nombre de
musulmans qui n'arriveront pas et on les
comprend des dessins de manière à
adhérer à cette république si la cub
pour objet que de dire quelque chose de
flou des mots qui sont abstraits qui ne
repose pas y compris sur un projet
social d'intégration ou d'assimilation
comme c'était le cas dans les siècles
précédents c'est pour ça que là on
retombe quand même sur un sujet de
nombre d' immigration massive qui a
quand même déséquilibre et 7,7 à cette
possibilité de vivre ensemble en
laissant notre histoire la république
n'a jamais été aussi forte et aussi
crédible et aussi accepté que quand l
accueil que quand elle intègre a dans
les mains quand elles ont si c'est ça
qui fait la force de l'universalité de
nos valeurs c'est ça la fois rugueux
lorsque je ne voudrais mettrait pas
d'accord sur ce point là mais on a bien
compris vos points de vue et
on continuera le débat je pense qu'il
n'est pas complètement terminée gilles
smadja a raison cette fois cette loi est
un gadget et apporte peu à l'arsenal
juridique existant c'est ce qu'estime
dhabi non internautes fidèles de figure
là et qu'on salue et hélène estime qu'il
n'est jamais trop tard pour bien faire
hélène répond ainsi à la question est il
déjà trop tard pour lutter contre le
séparatisme islamistes et effectivement
les internautes dans leur majorité
plutôt de pense pendant jury tout comme
hélas une petite majorité de 59% à 59 %
et thugs m&a pose une question qui
pourra faire matière à débat les lois de
la république doivent primer sur les
lois religieuses et bien tu games vous
lirez dans l'interview du figaro
magazine qui est fait donc par alexandre
ii vecchio avec les réponses de bernard
augier et de gérald darmanin et que leur
muse et carl meeus que jane harman
indique qu'il faut redonner une redonner
une transcendance à la république et est
la laïcité alors là justement c'est une
belle une belle
une belle question entre hugues les cas
de philosophie politique et une belle ça
donne une belle matière pour un prochain
débat on vous lâche on a explosé les
comptes d'au moins d'une dizaine de
minutes mais on était ravi de discuter
avec vous et de discuter ensemble merci
beaucoup de nous avoir suivi et on se
retrouve lundi sur figaro live a très
vite bon week end et si manuel macron
prend la parole bien sûr ce sera à
suivre en direct sur le site du figaro
et sur figaro l'âge
[Musique]